God forgive me God please forgive me
okay
okay so yeah I was thinking about the
other day I really I really I really
something is heavy on my mind that I
really need to to express this and to
tell somebody because I know since I've
been coming and telling telling you guys
things I've been giving you some pretty
deep stuff this this this this one goes
a little bit below below the boughs but
I have to tell it well I started out by
saying I was used to live in Santa
Monica California hangout I went to it
to it to alcohol rehab been down there
see I went out and got drunk one day and
I got put out so there's this grocery
store that I should go to and ice to pan
him every day so one day I'm panning
there you know every now and then I cuz
most I want to win I would I'll be
halfway drunk and I'd be flirting with
the girls
one day this lady she's coming out of
the snow she's going she's going into
the store and she's she's a she's a
Caucasian woman here's this blue light
blonde girl she's kind of thick she
weighs about 130 hundred forty pounds
she's got these big tits and he's really
big legs and she's got peach fuzz on my
legs I was like bog peach fuzz does he
wants in this store and I went she wants
to start it I said I say gorgeous how
you doing he got like he like like don't
bother me so I guess when she went in a
store she kind of thought about so she
came out of the store and she says oh my
I feel so bad I feel so bad she let me
give you a few dollars and I said well
the few dollars I I said I said you know
I'm a game I'm a gamer I said what the
topology likes cuz I seen her I start
coming in a store you know a lot of
times so you know some people I kind of
want to set up for the kill so when she
came up so well I feel so bad let me get
our song she drove up a Range Rover
truck too so she said well let me let me
give you a few bucks I said I don't want
you to stand and talk to me for me right
so let me just tell you tell me kind of
why I'm out he said well I was curious
about I see you sometime too and I'm
just curious about why you out here so
something told me this I always lie
about my alcohol ISM because I'm ashamed
my alcoholism but for something
something in my heart for some reason
when I looked at this lady in the eye
and she looked at me and I you know
there was there was something there it
was like it was like those like
a trust I got a truck I could trust us
well I've read that from my mama I was
in alcohol rehab and I read absent in my
on the street I don't know what the hell
to do I pan on my money you know I get
hotels at night I dream the while I
sleep by the beach on the beach our
blankets on the beach you know this guy
so
and she was like oh yes oh my god oh
dear oh dear you poor baby once you
start saying oh you poor baby I'm
thinking in my mind I'm I know I'm gonna
get y'all known for dumping I'm gonna
take this I'm gonna take this [__] to
the main but as we as I started talking
is she's trying to listen to what I was
saying it was like they're to me like he
was like they're dirty for me to talk to
her about things that I was talked about
so we became really good friends you
know we became really good friends
matter of fact that day I didn't that
day I didn't I didn't I wouldn't accept
any money for so one day about three
days later started raining and I saw
that the deep drilling with my cold is
sweat on her come on come on let's go to
buck I can't get a burger get him get
him get him get in now so whoa what the
hell if I jumped in the truck we were in
the truck in Aberdeen it's about a block
and a half down I bet you be seeing
world with that so why I'm you know a
Range Rover so uh glamour which it has a
the the dash on the front on this side
it's kind of big so it's got like a
section where you can put pictures in
there so I see her she's looking up I
would have what a cowboy have someone
with witness with us thought it was her
sister whatever and she's got this she's
got I see blue eyes and big tits pretty
face blue eyes liked it I don't really
actually well that's a nice picture
don't see he's going on so we went out
to eat I started telling them more about
you know so I said what so I started
thinking how can how can i how can I get
it I want I want some time when I talk
to you like this I would get a job and I
knew something about her spirit her
spirits connected and we just connected
I say you know I really need a job I
said dude anything done around the house
or can I come to your house and what she
said you know what she said she was from
they were from back East somewhere and
her her and her daughter he said her
daughter was with her dad well she was
due to come home within a month or
something like that to go to school
because it was somewhere laid off this
to me at August late August sometime she
said sure I really I really you know
I've been divorced for two years I
really haven't had a boyfriend anything
she said well let me just read more on
finished I really don't like people
around my daughter because my daughter
she's only 14 years old she's very
attractive
she's flirtatious she said well of
course she never really seen me with a
guy other than her father sit alone a
black guy says so see if she ever sees
you if she's here you see everything you
doing some Ron house I'm just telling
you to clean oh man what you really are
I'm probably that [__] at all so we get
to the house and she's got this he sits
in Santa Monica I was like near a new
marine Santa Monica came out it was
really really nice houses and all I'm
thinking to myself when I see this house
I know I know I know baby got money this
I know she got money and the precedent
let me just think I'm a cool guy so let
me just think all the things she needs
done around his house and then I get a
job longer and longer longer large so
what I said was she had a really big
gardener so well let me do the garden
and I looked in the back and it was just
like I like uh like house house in Santa
Monica the house in the front there's a
little house in the back that's like it
was like a tool shed made into a room I
said that's a nice little spot back
there she said you know what she said my
daughters getting of age she's having a
lot of friends and I want them to be
able to come here and do their thing
whatever he says so I need you to go in
there and clean and clean it up you know
straighten it up I have a there's an
attic on the top take the stuff in the
bottom put it up on the top and all this
stuff so so I'm there working for the
first time cleaning up she's like she's
loving what I'm doing she's loving what
I'm going all this time I don't want the
lady ever see me drink because once I
start drinking I'm thinking I know more
[__] us all off so anyway so that
night but the fourth night I was there I
was cleaning up me she asked me to
- coming house and have a drink and I
went in house and had a drink and pushed
in there talking and you know and all of
a sudden I don't know I don't know dude
I just I just cuz I it's like we had
like like a like a like a crush on each
other but you but we weren't really
fertile I didn't want to I kind of
thought she she liked me she was digging
oh man you ain't had sex in two years
but I knew I didn't I didn't want I
didn't want to come I wanted to give all
the money I get our first before I
[__] her anyway
that particular day I don't know we
sitting on the couch we looked at each
other and we're the [__] weren't we
in the [__] I [__] her we [__]
about we [__] for about three hours I
ain't no pushing a long time but we
[__] about three hours straight
and after we had sex I remember she sat
back on the couch and she she crossed
him she crossed her arms and she just
kept going Wow Wow what's wrong she said
I've never had she's just I don't never
six like that no my life oh my god I got
so many old guys if I can't count them
and I thought she was you know she she
probably all her [__] do that
yes I've never had a black guy before
him what the [__]
so now now we're pretty much where you
know I just wanted to have was sex we
were pretty much in a relationship now I
think about week a week or two went by
and I'm taking this stuff from the
bottom and putting up on the time region
to put someone at top so something fell
out of one of the boxing when if I was
going to on the tall tall this looming
ladder and when it fell down somebody
said I got it
and she caught it and she here you go so
I looked down I looked down I looked
down the stairs all I saw was big tits
and blue eyes
I said damn I said who are you she said
oh those daughter and I love testing I
know I'm thinking to myself guy and his
mother [__] fine shots ey seemed like
no me in tirana SUNY wanna come down and
then I guess heard all I wanted to be
[__]
it just got back I was just awkward
garage I actually kept her sitting here
she gave me get somebody [__] other
garage so we sat down ate dinner and
that of us this is so-and-so so-and-so
Donna and she gave me she get there
first her daughter game is look like
just [__] [__] with my with my
mama yeah yeah I felt it I feel she look
like [__] I near with my mom I think I
even heard on the phone talking to frame
when they say I was [__] with her
[__] or something like that she told
her well maybe our thing I was hearing
some like that
so about about about a month went by and
meet her mother yridian were really in
tightness now I'm sleeping with her
mother now I'm sleeping a mother but I
had this room in the back now she know
her mo I said her mother work nights she
worked issues like a like re and she
worked at night and I kind of worked in
the daytime when I worked when I work
where I was working I was kind of doing
my hustle so she was kind I won't you
just stay home
and you know you know she was gonna dick
pretty much when she just stay home and
clean up the house everything and I'll
take her to Bill don't you worry about
so long I got every man maybe I'll take
care of me I'm just you know so I was
drinking when I would always drink my
drink most one day I decided to go get
some crack Oh God and when got the crack
and some told me her daughter could
almost school like 3 o'clock in the
afternoon
no I better wait to her daughter comes
home desert playing whatever and go to
see whatever so I bought the cracking up
with the cracking is run a new [__] late
so I'm drinking the alcohol and I kind
of fell asleep and then I'll over heard
somebody no no no stop stop no stop stop
I said what the [__]
so about this time in her daughter got
kind of our the erotic he got cuz marry
me let me back up her daughter had told
her mom she said mom I like that guy she
said mom you she did you know I see
Stassi doing you and that guy look at
each other you guys are kind of main
features she said won't you cuz he
should we start arguing about my
drinking she said once you stop
bothering anybody drinking let him
drinking whatever he seems like a pretty
cool guy
so anyway weak on me and Huracan I got
close we became she comes go out coming
ever at a home on everything we kind of
got close but when he's when I first met
her she would give me this look like
[__] but then she started start
looking at me I don't know maybe maybe I
started fantasizing about how I want to
construe my I told myself I would never
do this but you know I'm on my man you
know I would I would I'll be looking at
her she and she always wore these she
always wear these biker shorts and we
should wear these biker shorts she
wouldn't put no panties on and you could
see her stuff in the front he goes
you're at crack in it back so what you
kind of when she walked I was just
trying not to look and she would always
kind of get put this grin on her face
when she walked by like she knew I was
checking around so one day when Onew got
Navy a calico so one day I was doing
oral sex on her mother and she walked by
the yeah we had to durable and she
walked by the moon was she she walks you
something she came in room and asked her
mother for and around with my face with
dinner man
so mommy 100 gone she slammed the door
oh my god I thought zombies and our
mother start crying oh my god did one my
daughter for then after that about a
week later is when I heard I was in the
room drinking then I had bought the
crack and I was in the room and I heard
no no no stop stop stop stop
well some guy she had in the room was
trying to I guess he was trying to rape
I know if they were [__] whatever and
I ran the room and I saw him I saw him
on top of her so I beat the kid up kid
I beat the kid I beat this cabbie I
[__] this kid [__] this kid I [__]
it cuz I was I was drunk on Cisco y'all
know I was drunk on Cisco wine I [__]
this kid I told his [__] kid if
I ever saw his that sort of [__] of my
stepdaughter
I'd kill his [__] ass hey you
can go home and get your [__]
daddy go and get your mama get that
[__] Polys
I said I'll [__] mouth this is my
[__] dog I pushed him out the
door now the girl went into she's
screaming ha gosh Mike if my mom finds
out my mom my father if she tells my dad
she said my dad he's gonna kill me other
one so she went and room was found right
here in her crotch I kind of had not
shown her like you know sighs oh I feel
first you know I feel for I feel
responsible for I never said anything to
her mother I never we never we never
talked about it
he never said [__] about it so one day
I'm in my room I still write this
cracker I get to crack it and I'm
watching this to Leave It to Beaver
somebody I'm bringing Cisco I'm gonna
take it she comes she comes in the room
and she comes in the room and she gets
in front of me
she said I really appreciate you not
telling my mother what I was doing she
said I really like you around I like you
my Lulu my mother I kind of like you
myself
she said I'll do anything for you and
she gave me a kiss on the lips now wait
a minute now I'm damn perfect but when
she but I was fantasizing I was kind of
fantasizing about that so when she came
in here and did it she's all kind of
[__] start turning my so my gosh oh god
I hope I'm never doing it I hope I don't
never done it so as she walked out and
turned around she's got her on me smile
and you know I was I was drunk on Cisco
y'all I said I thought I said it real
low I said [__] give me some of that
[__]
now I didn't think she heard me but she
did hear me so about a week later her
and her mother had it real I mean her
mother had this real bad fight about me
drinking out on me drink she never did
no one do that you had to crack because
I didn't once I know once I took a hit
off their pipe won't tell what I was
gonna do once you once you hit that
crack it all bets are off on morals
anything so I was sitting there drinking
I was smoking weed
so her mother so did the girl came in
and she said man since I'm tired of mom
getting on your house about your
drinking man you know now you're [__]
cool man you're cool you do help Rhonda
I'm tired of doing that [__] [__] I
said you know what sorry
I wanted to get back at her mother well
you know what you smoke weed oh god okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry saying that's people
you smoke weed she was [__] I did it
a couple of times how can you show me
how so she should we see they're hitting
the hitting the damn bike not the pipe
of hitting hitting hitting the joint and
I got
- Cisco on the ground so you wanna try
some Cisco anyway she was she was pretty
fun she was pretty [__] [__] up so
we sitting there on the couch and she
said I think I heard her say you really
want to [__] me I didn't when she said
that I was I'm we must watch it leave it
to be overseas until you really want to
[__] me and I and I I thought I was I
thought it was wrong I thought I was
fantasizing I knew she didn't say no
[__] like she did not say that
so on Manny got my I thought I said
she's looking at me kinda like like a
little drunk girl I looked at her I said
no I said I should I be dead and say no
no no sure it does attack this little
[__] get the [__]
so I said let me let me let me let me be
a man now I say you know what
how could you don't dare you dare you
say something like that to me I'm in
love with your mother
how dare she say well you're the one who
said it you're the one who initiated you
you're the one who wants to [__] me I
didn't say I want to [__] you so me well
we kind of gig we kind of laughed about
it but [__] I was but deep down I was
ready I mean I wanted I wanted inside
kind of one I said well I don't want to
stay where it right now
two days later your mother had to go to
meeting room nurse's meeting or
something like that see what I'll be
able to relate and her daughter was
there and I was already drunk on Cisco
and for some reason the little room I
was like I cleaned up I clean the room
up its gonna get really intimidating
come on - I live in a back up after I
[__] her mother her mother said that
room is yours
she said you ain't going to doing one
over that room was yours it till you get
somewhere to stay cuz she could stay
another room cuz she's been a [__]
because her daughter was coming like I
to add a to coming
plus he so she's only she can stand
alone you got you won't stay right there
in a room like I'm you won't be my boy
toy something she said like that but
you're gonna stay in a more seamless I
think you know fixing what foods I had
just couches real black couch Isis kind
of sentiment has just kind of seen
anyone sitting in the chair and she came
out I was sitting there talking you know
we start smoking weed and she laid on
the couch she had just got the [__]
black hearse or try to get the she had
his biker shorts only she laid on the
couch and now she never wore panties in
a biker so so with the way she kind of
lay down on the Hohner stomach she's got
a head our Leacock don't well you could
see kind of sear of a diner
sticking out to here
and I knew I should've never hit that
[__] bike that when I put that crack
on that bike all all the fantasies that
I had all the [__] that I would want to
do tour I'd go with Dora there was no
more there was no more I shouldn't be do
nothing nothing to me told me someone
said just [__] the [__] I looked at
laying on the couch so I eased up
moaning oh God and I'm I pulled her
short to the sign I started to put my
tongue on her parts and I started I
started having more sex with her and I
kind of thought you know when you smoke
cocaine you get paranoid so I kind of
thought I was art I thought I felt a
move I so [__] she's gonna come so
anyway I remember why not when I want to
raised up to put another internal fight
when I put the cocaine we just won't
crack it's she wakes up she turns around
she said oh my god oh my god dude I
can't explain the [__] the way I feel
I feel like a [__] wife I feel worse
than the child I felt exhausted some
parts of mansome with me and I said so
I'm hearing hump but now I'm paranoid on
the crack and I'm thinking the Polys are
coming from the roof her father's coming
with the shotgun and the mother's coming
with and I just pump in it I still got
the hump in the die she said pulled her
shorts off and said man you might as
well [__] finish what you guys
started I'm horny anyway 40 years old
we had sex oh I had sex but I did for
the rubble I am the first time I put it
all wrong
I feel so ashamed what had done I blamed
it on the Kraken how I said Oh baby I
said I'm in love with your mother I
should have never done this it's just a
dog it's a cocaine and how Coster I feel
so bad ice please don't ever tell me why
she said it with a grin well I could
like just full grin on her face please
don't ever tell anybody
three days went by four days in a pile
we did it again did she started actually
for it we started having sex on a
constant basis I say two or three times
a week two or three times a week so her
mother told me one day she said well
so-and-so she's been throwing up and
doing kind of crazy stuff I'm coming I
don't know how uh she said she asked she
asked me does she have boys around at
night I saw no she would never say no
she didn't have boys around Mike so
mother kind of looked you know yeah well
okay I think what she was thinking was
like are you are you [__] like ah nah
so she said because she did she didn't
reach anyone that she's at you and so
I'm sorry you guys are kidding kind of
friend you guys are always do question
you have to get to friend easy to you
you get you get to friend of my
daughter's you don't want it 28 anyway I
had a cousin who was a doctor who knew a
doctor and I said I got this my
next-door neighbor has a daughter and
she has I'm I'm a mentor of her
boyfriend and her daughter's boyfriend
and he thinks that his girlfriend is
pregnant so can we how can we get it
know how can we get abortion so he said
he told me how to go about the day huh
do not fill out paper in this particular
place you didn't you didn't you could be
anonymous and do it whatever long as you
had the phone at eyes you could be an
ominous one little do Mickey Mouse [__]
so ooh I end up talking her into going
to do a so what will we talked about I
so will you be better for us it just had
abortion because that way you know I'm
that way if I we get divorce and we'll
have to worry about [__] I said we'll
never do this again
we would never did this is it this is it
matter of fact I quit drinking and
smoking I've tried to go on a if we're
drinking it that [__] me up so bad in
the air
I mean I have morals there's no one I'm
drinking this smoking I don't I'm
drinking smoking I don't know [__] [__]
anything anywhere any kind of way to go
when you own a crack but when I'm so
wrong I'm now cool um I'm remorseful and
shameful about this [__] so we stop we
stop [__] around so about six months
go by she does she turn like 1550 now
she got a boyfriend and I know I could
hear him sex I know and I'm walking him
some time having sex in a room and I
never say nothing but I started getting
because I I'm not we had a relationship
I I had a crush on I liked her so I said
I was drunk one day I said [__] this
[__]
I'm gonna start [__] his [__] again
how dare he coming in and [__] my [__]
there he come get that's my [__]
that's my that's my little [__] so
about a week went by and I started we
talk we start having sex again
so about oh so about a month later her
mother says just call me big Lou big Lou
you got to get your stuff and go now let
me let me do my head I say again I said
she gonna call the police for [__] that
she told me her daddy was a shotgun when
a shotgun would fit in the snuff on our
side I just I just knew I was gonna walk
up doing Kiki when I said she never say
anything but I thought it's because she
said was so and so she started she
started her mother start breaking down
crying screaming I said what she said
she's she's praying she's pregnant
I didn't know she wasn't a virgin she
paid she's praying she pregnant but I
didn't think it was even her I had
nothing to do with it because I said
well she had a boyfriend and but that's
when I touched it when she got a
boyfriend I hear him in there I said I
said that [__] real quick
she got a boyfriend I thought of her
[__] actually I think my enough oh I
thought her [__] he retreated I know
I know I know I heard [__] alert or
[__] we'll just do what she said once
you kick his ass for me again I keep the
kids I ask what she said but her mother
you know the exhale mother knows her her
mother her mother always had a little
click you know I guess I guess she could
she could watch us flirt at least
forgive each other all the time we were
terribly soon we were there to get their
night all the time we even though we
were father we were like the press the
plan we were really cool I mean it was
chick we were really cool so I left the
house in that 4x4 bottle before I left
the house and
and now without and I really I really
like this like nothing I really like
this leg I mean I reach see I mean I
really liked her because she was so
sweet to me she would she just she was
really nice to me but really a real
friend so I kept trying to make excuses
to come back to the house and come back
at also in error so I guess about for
about four years I try to try to get
back while I can get back with her so I
see when I saw her again she was 20 she
was her darling between she was 21 so 14
15 17
I sold seven seven years later now this
is the seven years later I guess I it
kind of put it to the back of my mind
but I start I would behind this [__] I
had drinking sauce but drink it's so
[__] heavy off so one day you know I
said just letting this little job and
had a little car the Wolf's wagon and on
Friday night I will go down to
particular Boulevard and I would always
pick up girls
I was my thing I picked up hoes I'm
still I like else I would always go pick
up holes with the particular place I was
going to they only had black girls and
in Mexican girls so one day I'm going
down the [__] Boulevard on bottle
48th or something like that in here I
seen long white legs and big tits in his
long blonde hair and blue eyes
and I said god damn and I stopped the
car I said what's up baby and she said
what's up with you man let's list this
date go jump go ass in the car so we
jump in the car and we know we just work
what you doing here no I remember before
we got to the room she said you look
familiar to me nice to know you because
I'm already embarrassed well beyond ego
you don't know me you don't know we've
no goddamn want you you show them only
so anyway we [__] we had really good sex
we had really good sex I guess I guess
if you if you had sex or somebody you I
wanna have sex water it was like it was
like it was like it was like I [__]
her before I mean it was like something
something something something going on
here so I really liked it we kind of we
hit it off we were talking so I still
want a what the second time we did it
second of every Friday my car gave her
hundred are you running out to pops
every time I come over Friday given an
office give me a couple of hours a week
okay so the second time she came I said
you you such a nice-looking intelligent
young leave why would you come on she
said well I got printed a few years ago
my mom meanwhile got into a city put me
out
just go who's kind of you'd pin me and
put me out here so I read him now just
kind of do this [__] three nights on
home
I didn't think there's no buyer so I
said well [__] it you know what so well
yeah I was down saying like a nice tan
halfway house she can't come stay with
me but we still don't know who we were
we still didn't work but I remember her
saying she thought I look familiar and I
kind of thought when I [__] like I
[__] her before so about the fifth
time you know I started liking I see you
know what I said I'm let's go
I'll GE I took it to the black anger so
let's go to the black is my birthday so
I'm awarded black Kings I'm taking the
Black Angus we're heat talk geez let me
show you a picture well my son when he
turned eight years old she showed me
that picture when I saw this [__] kid
this [__] looks so much like me
I if I remember when I saw the picture
and I called her the daughter's name and
she's called my name she said oh my God
we're like oh my god so we admit we
admit he's like would we admit again she
was she was 2 or 21 years old but you
know when you were younger you look
different and we will we meet once we
once she don't recognize me she was she
looked through the same she got us gamla
wait what she look the same and I cried
we cried we cried we cried I mean I
remember I'm gonna cry right there table
then people was giving us nothing are
you guys okay I said I want to see my
son she said my mother told me that if I
ever saw you again don't let her know
because she was going to have my
cousin's blow your [__] head off
and my father said if you ever heard
that you came near me again he was gonna
tie you to something something real
heinous he was gonna do to me dick
they're they're after you to kill you
and I said well can I can I can I can I
at least see my son one time she won't
let me see my son you know that she that
that's all they had to I had to had the
girl on that this son and I know I know
and I again I couldn't I couldn't see my
kid and I kind of went into a rage so I
got I got in jail I beat some somebody
off now I beat someone but I went to
jail and I got out I got sober again and
I was I guess when I started driving a
truck I want North one day I'm up north
one day and you know we stopped a few
much okay it's called it's called the
petrol trust
pit Petro truck stop I stopped my truck
now I'm putting my field in that note
the trucks out husband he had the truck
stopped here you got the the the movies
over here you got the showers over here
you got the restaurant over here I look
up at the window there her mother is
with this guy and they sitting down now
where the truck is facing this way the
windows over here and I'm going on this
side of the truck filled fueling the
truck I got there not you got when you
through the truck is sound like a car
now the what you just kind of pop it
into the tank and you squeeze the thing
and just walk off from it it's it's
probably gas when I saw this lady in
this restaurant he struck style
restaurant I don't know what made her
look up and when she saw me I I guess I
guess before I guess the way we looked
he said was like oh I was I we did this
movie love song like I heard I heard I
heard this I heard this ladies scream
dude I knew I said somebody finally
catch me out of these hills they finna
be to step in and kill me
dude I ran around
the side I jumped in that [__] read I
put the [__] push the goddamn button
started a truck up and I took off now I
remember
remember when I left the nozzle was
theater this joke
so wait to the hospital [__] [__]
the house copped out I mean you won't
feel shooting on you want every goddamn
with and one other touch with guard down
so I had look I had to turn the CBO
everybody
Robert are you go what where did you see
you didn't run off with the goddamn and
the people from the casting ran out dude
on Laos oh I was shipping when I got to
that [__] energy I had I had a I had
a head up head up head up you go with a
475 cat if you know we're at 13 double
driver and I bet you I was going I know
I was gonna run him out not so for about
five days all I could think about was
every time I saw blue light or the
Polish day was coming there was still
the day was coming it was coming to get
me so this particular incident happened
from 15-20 years ago until this day I
still have nightmares that these people
are going to get me and I never taught
never have it ever ever ever told nobody
nothing [__] so when I come in here and
I dump this deep ass [__] you know I
kind of went before I God I was scared
as hell like I said man if I tells
people I had sex with a 14 of girl not
so much the first time at 6 a boner
gotta pray the first time it is sex I
got afraid of the gig about joseffer
over over over boyfriend and it beat him
up beat the other kid up and saw our
mother and dads after everybody's
everybody's [__] after me well it
would be he'll if he see me you don't
you to [__] her and me go I did it now
I'm sorry for it and I hope if he ever
sees this video for mother and sees this
video I can get release and I'll just
say I'm sorry I'm sorry if we're doing
that dude daughter marbles I own crap no
visitor one alcohol but I'm truly from
the bottom of my heart I'm [__] sorry
I'm really sorry and I hope you apology
all your daughter apology I really would
like to seek my son I know he's not
someone songs he look just like each
other like man that [__] was so
much like me it was scary like a [__]
troll I saw the movie with what what's
his name Will Smith when he had the
three people to look I need
[__] hood even he was the exact
identity of me I don't like to be in his
life I like to say alright you know
Steve the thing didn't teach him not to
go the wrong way and God did and
encouraged him that even though his
mother's doing what she doing I really
feel bad because Rob because I feel like
she's a hooker because of me because I
screwed her life up and if she's looking
at this video I'm so sorry I am so sorry
from the bottom are I pick it him into
you any kind of way I can I know I can't
see you because because you guys are
gonna blow my hair off but I want you
because something tells me somebody is
one of y'all is looking at just I'm I
apologize I really do I really a part of
knock knocking maybe I can get a little
more or more sleep at night and and and
and thankful that meet here uh-huh
thanks let me take let me [__] I got ya
I don't don't know don't look me and I
guess I'm I'm some to exchange gene
that's her that I told you I told you
already I told I tell you I'm here yes
dad told I was here yeah yeah yeah it's
it's really it's really emotional for me
so I can't come I can't believe I'm
talking about this year but I guess I
trust you man I'm you know what the only
by me anyway like I was like wasn't I
shake it movie game juice is true
catch me if you can anyway oh yeah yeah
cuz I mean yeah I miss and I yeah I'm
sorry I mean I'm me for the bottom
bottle my heart sorry I had a like I say
had a beer at home before I got here
I've got